Hier zijn 3 methoden voor het maken
van een scherpe vouw bij het breien
een gevouwen band. Schuif eerst
een enkele steek langs de vouw
lijn, programmeer uw machine of handmatig
schuif het midden uit,
naai elke andere rij.
Dit zal een lijn van langwerpige stiksels
aan de breikant van het breiwerk.
Een andere methode is het toevoegen
van een randje nadat de band klaar is.
Begin met het weglaten van een
naald als je breit de band.
Laat een contrasterend garen of
wat ravelijnkoord door de ladders.
Dit zal helpen bij het
oppakken van die hechtingen.
Vervolgens zullen we de naalden erdoorheen
duwen de ladders, met de
parelkant naar voren.
Leg het breiwerk over het naaldbed en
voorzichtig de naalden erdoorheen trekken.
Wees er zeker van dat je niet vangt
de strengen van de steken
aan elke kant van de ladder
Je wilt gewoon die naalden om
door de openingen te prikken.
Met de hand, zorgvuldig
vormgeven enkele grote steken.
Overweeg het gebruik van een
contrasterende kleur voor
een interessant randje.
Als alle steken zijn gevormd, het breiwerk
en de bindoff te vouwen door te trekken
steek door steek om die te
beveiligen stiksels en maak de vouw.
De hechtingen moeten los
zijn, maar niet slordig.
Voortbouwend op die vorige versie,
een meer decoratieve versie, is
geïnspireerd door Mary
Anne Oger van KnitWords.
Deze keer zal de naald weer
buiten het werk gelaten worden
van het werk om een kolom te
creëren van ladders voor de Edge.
Maar voordat je de band gaat vervangen,
gebruik een dubbele streng garen
en e-wrap over de naalden.
Brei dan een rij met een
enkele streng garen.
en het garen te breken.
Met de gordelzijde naar voren,
trek hetzelfde aantal naalden door
de ladderrand, net als vroeger.
Deze keer gebruikte ik de kousenband en
het het echt sneller heeft laten gaan.
Daarna voorzichtig nieuwe
steken met de hand breien
door de ladderopeningen en
de steken op de naalden.
Maak de hechtingen los en
uniform, maar niet slordig.
Bindoff door stiksteeksteek
te trekken om af te werken.
De verdubbelde e-wrap zorgt
niet alleen voor een knapperige
rand, maar het voegt een decoratieve
Vlechten langs die rand.
Nogmaals, dit werken in een contrasterende
kleur zou heel interessant kunnen zijn.
Een ding om op te merken
met deze techniek is
dat de rand wel heeft een
goede en een slechte kant.
Houd hier dus rekening mee
bij het plannen van je trui.